et s'est invité en duplex de nantes avec
nous ce matin sur lci et sarah elle a
irrigué la secrétaire d'état en charge
de la jeunesse et du service national
universel
madame bonjour
alors je sais que vous enjoindre congé
mais je sais aussi que vous suivez
l'actualité forcément et vous suivez
notamment j'imagine le drame qui a
touché
la ville de colmar et cette petite
communauté afghane suite à ce qui s'est
passé il ya quelques jours un jeune
homme dont qui faisait du rodéo avec sa
moto il a été interpellé parce qu'il
faisait du bruit il a été interpellé par
ce jeune afghan il revient avec une arme
de poing il tire il le tue il est en
fuite vous qui êtes secrétaire d'état à
la jeunesse ça vous a inspiré quoi vous
avez pensé quoi quand vous avez appris
ça
savez dans notre pays il y a des lois et
les doigts sont faites pour être
respectées
on a lutté contre les rodéos urbains
parce que ça crée effectivement beaucoup
de nuisances pour les riverains et ça a
été un combat à l'assemblée nationale
sous lens un quinquennat là c'est un
acte de violence au delà enfin j'espère
que la mesure et les contraintes seront
fermes qu'il y aura des conséquences
immédiates parce que jamais jamais
aucune violence ne doit être justifiée
ni tolérer alors madame aillerie en
l'occurrence là il ya une part de rodéo
urbain effectivement parce que le gars
était là avec sa moto mais il n'a pas
été coursé par la police et c'était un
peu particulier comme contexte est ce
qu'il vous semble que la loi actuelle
pour lutter contre ces fameux rodéo qui
sont pratiqués que par des jeunes des
cités en quelque sorte qui date de 2018
est suffisante ou est-ce qu'il faut la
réaménager pour permettre notamment aux
policiers d'intervenir directement sur
ces jeunes qui prennent la fuite devant
eux mais qu'ils n'ont pas le droit
d'interpeller
vous savez la priorité des priorités
c'est d'appliquer cette loi telle
qu'elle est et si elle doit être
améliorée
renforcer et bien le temps arrivera mais
ça ne part jamais d'un fait divers ça ne
part jamais d'une situation particulière
moi ce que je sais c'est que aujourd'hui
nos forces de l'ordre mais lutte sans
relâche contre les dix ans contre les
rodéos contre la délinquance quel que
soit notre territoire est plus que
jamais moi j'ai envie de saluer leur
travail et les c'est évidemment le temps
aux parlementaires et bien d'évaluer loi
qui a été votée il n'y a pas si
longtemps et voir s'il ya des
améliorations à faire mais toujours
faire attention de ne pas partir d'un
fait particulier pour une généralité
aujourd'hui les rodéos urbains sont des
vrais fléau dans nos villes il y en a à
nantes il y en a malheureusement à
colmar il en adopte beaucoup de villes
françaises plus que jamais la saisie des
biens
l'interpellation des jeunes qui font des
rodéos et leur condamnation et la mesure
nécessaire pour beaucoup de fermeté
ensuite bien sûr beaucoup d'éducation et
de prévention la responsabilité des
parents dans cette éducation bien sûr
toujours parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier
que ce sont des engins motorisés qui
sont utilisés et au delà de ça plus que
jamais de la sécurité routière parce
qu'on sait que ça provoque des accidents
et ça met en danger des vies eric
decouty à une question pour vous madame
oui madame alary on entend ne pas réagir
ce réagir fait divers vous avez dit donc
vous considérez que la déclaration de
gérald darmanin il ya quelques jours de
modifier la loi justement à chaud après
une succession de deux épisodes en
région parisienne était une mauvaise
idée et qu'aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le
sujet gérald darmanin s'est trompé selon
vous absolument pas absolument pas le
ministre de l'intérieur est compétent
sur le la tranquillité publique sur
l'ordre public sur la sécurité et encore
une fois il est le premier en charge de
cette sécurité du quotidien et donc ils
évaluent cette loi avec les
parlementaires et s'il faut la modifier
il faudra la modifier mais encore une
fois je ne crois pas que ce soit utile
en tout cas aujourd'hui moi je suis en
charge de cette jeunesse en charge de
l'engagement en charge des chemins
d'émancipation et je suis une
parlementaire et parce que j'étais
député alors je sais à quel point ce
travail d'évolution de la loi se fait
avec le ministre concerné et les
parlementaires la mairie vous êtes en
charge
notamment du service national universel
qui intéresse en priorité les jeunes de
15 à 17 ans alors on sait pourquoi et
dans quel état d'esprit ce service
national a été mis en place mais par
exemple dans la situation actuelle de
l'armée française qui manque de
personnel qui manque peut être de
vocation et d'attrait est ce qu'il vous
semble que ce s est nul appelons le
comme ça peut être un élément aspirants
et inspirant pour les jeunes
le service national universel c'est
d'abord une aventure citoyenne le
service national universel n'est pas le
service militaire il a vocation à créer
de l'engagement de la mixité un temps
aussi de compréhension entre nos
jeunesse revenons à l essence même nos
jeunes ne se croise plus entre 15 et 17
ans un jeune de colmar un jeune de
nantes un jeune d'aurillac un jeune de
guéret n'a plus finalement de temps en
commun et bien pour créer sept ans et
pour qu'ils puissent apprendre apprendre
les gestes qui sauvent apprendre à
réagir devant des incendies apprendre à
réagir devant des intempéries mais aussi
finalement vivre la république au
quotidien c'est à dire se rendre compte
à quel point eh bien ils ont des points
communs le service national mersey les
faits pour ça d'abord c'est pour ça
qu'il est encadrée par des l'éducation
nationale le monde associatif et des
corps en uniforme des réservistes ou des
retraités de nos armées pour finalement
gardé l'excellence des trois
l'excellence de nos armes et
l'excellence de l'éducation nationale et
l'excellence du monde associatif et de
l'engagement bénévole c'est pour ces
jeunes que nous investissons pour qu'ils
aient finalement les moyens de
s'épanouir de trouver leur place dans
notre société de devenir des bénévoles
de refaire des services civiques pour
aller avoir suffisamment d'énergie
découvrir l'europe et d'yves leur
citoyenneté européenne notre jeunesse
elle a besoin d'abord d'un champ des
possibles de plus d'égalité des chances
tout ça en créant du commun c'est pour
ça qu'il est le service national
universel c'est pour ça que ça ne coûte
rien aux parents qu'il n'y ait pas de
d'inégalité d'accès par la situation
sociale voilà le projet qu'elle celui du
service national vers celle créée encore
plus l'allemande de commun de collectif
et de patriotisme je vous entends bien
madame l ail rim et pourtant
c'est pas forcément facile tous les
jours avec les jeunes vous même par
exemple il ya quelques années vous avez
été confrontés à un problème vous avez
une prise de parole publique avec des
jeunes ensuite vous avez suggéré que
soit chanté la marseillaise il voulait
pas la chanter la marseillaise s'est pas
bien passé entre eux et vous ce ne sont
pas ces jeunes là qui vont au service
national universel
ce sont d'autres jeunes ce projet du
service national universel non le projet
du service d'ascione vercel il est
d'être paré sens universel c'est à dire
des jeunes qui viennent de situations
diverses on ne leur demande pas s'ils
sont en décrochage ou s'ils ont une
mention très une mention à leurs brevets
on leur demande pas s'ils viennent des
beaux quartiers où des quartiers les
plus en difficulté on leur demande vient
de venir vivre un aventure citoyenne
d'abord et avant tout et c'est pour ça
que si ces jeunes qui ne souhaitait pas
un moment chanter cette marseillaise
absolument essentiel parce que c'est
d'un commun se retrouve avec d'autres
jeunes et que tous les matins il lève
notre drapeau qu'il chante notre
marseillaise et que l'après midi ils
font du sport qu'ils découvrent nos
institutions et qu'il crée ce souvenir
commun ce creuset républicain
alors j'ai la certitude que entre eux eh
bien ils bâtiront une société plus forte
notre jeunesse elle n'est pas uniquement
notre avenir allait notre présent et
entre 15 et 17 ans et bien il y a des
fondamentaux qui sont acquis et je crois
que se dire vivre un séjour de séjour de
cohésion et ensuite rendre aussi en
allant découvrir le mode associatif en
s'engageant à la espère en faisant en
rejoignant les cadets la gendarmerie en
rejoignant les réserves qu'elles soient
désarmés ou de l'éducation nationale eh
bien on prend sa place il n'y a pas plus
beau moment qu'un moment où l'on
retrouve de la fierté dans le regard de
ses parents ou dans le regard de ces
encadrants et là c'est un équilibre
entre finalement un nouveau droit un
droit pour tous pour toute notre
jeunesse évidemment et bien cette
responsabilité ce devoir de s'engager et
de trouver l'engagement qui nous
épanouir le plus quelles que soient les
défis qui sont les nôtres aujourd'hui la
solitude l'environnement la crise
climatique ou encore simplement et bien
cette nécessité de créer de la cohésion
sociale eric decouty jouer malin tombe
bien votre votre discours sur
l'engagement et c'était que créer un
creuset européen c'est au coeur de l'été
il ya une proposition qui pourrait
participer à créer ce
européens notamment pour les jeunes
celle d'accorder le droit de vote
aux étrangers aux élections tous les
étrangers tous les étrangers est ce que
vous trouvez que c'est de nature ans a
été discuté un peu controversé ce que
vous pensez que cette idée là pour être
de nature a justement participé un
élément d'intégration notamment des plus
jeunes
t aujourd'hui il y à cette proposition
de loi qui a été mon rêve de déposer par
sacha oublier qu'un de mes collègues à
l'assemblée nationale et président de la
commission des lois il se trouve que moi
à titre très personnel je n'y suis pas
favorable pour une raison toute simple
mes parents ont été naturalisés et pour
participer à la vie citoyenne de notre
pays eh bien ils ont fait le choix de
rentrer dans notre communauté nationale
maintenant est ce que fait revivre le
séjour le service national universel
faire vivre des temps de cohésion comme
le service civique mais bien sont
ouverts à notre jeunesse qui sont sur
notre territoire bien sûr ça a vocation
à créer cette unité quel que soit en
réalité la nationalité de la personne
sur nos territoires maintenant
l'expression démocratique du vote même
si aujourd'hui elle est ouverte aux
citoyens européens pour les élections
municipales moi je pense à titre
personnel et le débat arrivera à la
rentrée au sein de la majorité que il a
quelque chose de fort que de demander à
rentrer dans notre communauté nationale
et de faire une demande de
naturalisation
d'accord donc vous en tout cas madame
elle ahurie si vous aviez à voter pour
aux comptes vous voteriez contre avec
ses arguments là c'est clairement
entendu le débat s'ouvrira certainement
et j'ai partagé un avis en tout cas une
conviction très personnel vous même je
crois savoir que vous êtes
membre de la réserve citoyenne de
gendarmerie c'est bien ça
tout à fait les très proches je crois
que chacun
pour dent dans le cadre de cette réserve
cette même colonne alain je crois donc
cette réserve citoyenne de gendarmerie
pratiquement vous êtes susceptibles
d'être appelés pour venir filer un coup
de main ou quoi
ils se trouvent il se trouve que
actuellement je suis membre du
gouvernement mais quand je ne l'était
pas quand on fait partie de la réserve
bien sûr qu'on s'engage on apporte une
compétence une expertise du temps et
savez dans notre pays le plus important
c'est de trouver finalement là où on a
on est plus utile là où on a un pouvoir
d'agir que l'on soit volontaire
sapeurs-pompiers et on a vu à quel point
ils sont absolument essentielles
aujourd'hui dans la lutte contre les
incendies que l'on rejoignent les cadets
de la gendarmerie en étant un peu plus
jeunes en permettant des actions de
sensibilisation d'ailleurs sur les
incendies par exemple puisque c'est
notre actualité ou lutter contre la
solitude quand il ya de la canicule
quand on rejoint une réserve celle de la
police ou encore je pense à la réserve
de l'éducation nationale eh bien on met
à disposition de notre nation de notre
grand pays une expertise et un
savoir-faire comme on sait le mettre à
disposition d'une association
quand on est bénévole et bénévoles
engagés
d'ailleurs je lance un appel aujourd'hui
à tous ceux qui ont envie de participer
est bien au fait de re créer et bien nos
forêts rebâtir notre patrimoine voire le
reste aurait mal malheureusement du fait
des dégâts que nous avons subies avec
ses feux géant où elles rejoignent et je
veux aider point gouv.fr c'est une
réserve c'est une ré verse une réserve
citoyenne où il y a des missions qui
sont proposés par des associations mais
aussi par des collectivités parce que
nous avons besoin de cette résilience
française nous avons besoin de cette
force française qui nous permettra est
bien de rénover deux parfois redonner à
voir ma à notre patrimoine naturel mais
aussi à notre patrimoine culturel et
historique mais aussi simplement
redonner du lien et recréer du lien
malheureusement il y a des dégâts est
plus que jamais nous avons besoin de
cela de ce lien fort alors rejoignez
cette réserve il ya un certain nombre de
missions et je pense que c'est aussi ça
faire émerger son pouvoir d'agir il nous
reste une toute petite minute la maladie
est une question des règles question qui
est un peu chiant peut-être un peu de
votre chambre de compétences mais c'est
la jeunesse il ya un certain nombre
d'informations qui sont publiés
aujourd'hui c'est la rentrée
universitaire dans quelques semaines et
que les étudiants sont en grande
difficulté parce que le coût est
extrêmement important encore dans ce
sens dans les grandes difficultés donc
que faire pour 7 pour ses jeunes ses
étudiants il y à il y a d'abord
effectivement urgence celle
d'accompagner cette rentrée pour les
étudiants 1 le gel évidemment des coûts
d'inscription le retour du repas un euro
qu'on n'a jamais arrêté
puis le coc vide pour tous les étudiants
boursiers c'est le repas un euro au sein
des crous il y à une aide exceptionnelle
qui est versée celle de 100 euros à tous
les étudiants boursiers plus et ceux qui
ont des appels les jeunes qui ont des
appels mais d'abord et avant tout
baisser le coût de la sécurité sociale
puisque nous avons supprimé sa
cotisation et enfin j'ai envie de vous
dire la mobilisation de toutes les
forces en présence la loi pouvoir
d'achat qui a été voté à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat permettra
évidemment du pouvoir d'achat pour tous
depuis hier il se trouve qu'il ya une
aide exceptionnelle pour également
pouvoir acheter un vélo un vélo qu'il
soit
classique ou électrique est les deux à
peu près 200 250 euros jusqu'à 2000
euros pour les vélos qui ont des cargos
ou des remorques plus que jamais on sait
que cette inflation touche d'abord les
hydrocarbures et le carburant aux
étudiants qui ont des déplacements qui
peuvent être faits en vélo en complément
de ce que fait déjà les ce que font déjà
les universités n'hésitez pas aussi à
faire évoluer vos moyens de locomotion
quand malheureusement il n'y a pas de
transports en commun entre le logement
et le site universitaire mais nous
sommes aux côtés de nos étudiants avec
sylvie retailleau et bien cette rentrée
elle sera complète il y a un à un
certain nombre d'accompagnements sociaux
d'abord mais aussi jamais hésité à
pousser la porte du crous parce qu'il ya
des aides spécifiques